so the topic of my talk tonight is a
history of computers and chess and and
along the way or as an integral part of
that an explanation of artificial
intelligence and what what artificial
how artificial intelligence developed
recently last several years and in
particular the application to chess that
the title is a little bit of a joke so
22 years ago
I wrote the Complete Idiot's Guide to
chess it was the last thing I did as a
professional chess player and the book
actually has been in print ever since
and in fact the publisher which is now
penguin approached me about eight nine
months ago maybe nine nine ten months
ago and they asked me they said we're
we're rebranding the whole Complete
Idiot's Guide series brand and we were
beginning with a couple of titles and
we'd like for your title the chess book
to be one of the ones to begin with and
so they are rebranding it how to play or
how to do X like a boss not my choice of
title it's their it's their new title so
the the book how to play chess like a
boss actually is literally on sale in
the next few days and I spent a couple
months - of updating the material of the
book and I spent a particular emphasis
on the chapter and computers in chess
because obviously that was somewhat out
of date some years later and so my guide
is the guide from a completed idiot to
you as I taught myself quite a lot about
computers in chess and in particular
artificial intelligence so I'm moving
ahead so there's a very long history of
chess being significant for computer
science going all the way back to 1949
Claude Shannon who was one of the
preeminent computer scientists of his
time wrote a paper
where he specifically argued that chest
was an ideal problem for computer
science scientists to really focus on in
order to develop what was then sort of a
nascent and evolving computer science
knowledge and he specifically called out
four reasons the first the problem is
very sharply defined in terms of the
allowed operations and the ultimate goal
right so you want a problem that's
really sharply defined for computer
science the second is on the one hand
it's not so simple to be trivial we're
not talking tic-tac-toe but on the other
hand it's not so difficult to be
intractable
it was a problem that you could imagine
seventy years ago
that computers could somehow really gain
traction address solve and whatever it
would mean to solve chess the third
reason is chess as a thinking game right
and this is important because it means
that if the methods of computer science
could be applied successfully to chess
it would either have to force us to
admit the possibility of mechanized
thinking or it would really force us to
reconsent flaws what thinking is what
what we mean by thinking so so not only
is chess a a well-defined problem that
that was um difficult but not too
difficult it was also one that could be
meaningful and then finally the discrete
nature of chess was very important right
it's a it's a very sort of binary game
there are specific moves specific
outcomes it it's it's it's not just
well-defined its sharply defined in a
way that really is important for
computer science and I would argue that
it was a really brilliant insight
because not only has chess proven to be
very fruitful for computer scientists I
think it continues to prove so-so
seventy years later just still is a very
useful problem for computer scientists
as we'll see so a few things kind of
characterize the early history of
computers and chess the first and it's
important for us to remember this there
was actually a
very sharp debate between whether brute
force which is the method that actually
turned out to to be the most successful
for decades should be applied or whether
artificial intelligence should be
applied now artificial intelligence is
not actually a very well-defined term
and we'll come back to this in more
detail later it really just live
describes a whole different set of
approaches but in the end brute force
was actually the approach that really
worked it turned out that even though at
first computer is sort of using specific
algorithms by brute force what I mean is
you're writing the algorithm you're
telling the computer exactly what to do
how to search how to evaluate how it
should choose a move or what rules that
should apply to choose a move and in
each position at first it turned out you
know to be a sort of very rudimentary
level but it kept making very steady
progress for a very long time initially
it's kind of funny there were very over
optimistic projections by computer
scientists and at the same time there
was almost complete complacency by chess
players such that I'm 51 years old and I
remember even in the 1970s in the early
to mid 1980s there really wasn't like
chess players just didn't think about
computers really being meaningful as
potential opponents or now it's engines
obviously we use them all the time and I
used this example other renowned
computer scientist Herbert Simon
predicted in 1957 that a computer would
be the world chess champion within ten
years right so on the one hand he was
obviously wildly all over optimistic he
was off by three decades but he was
right and at the end and you know at the
time and for a few decades afterwards
chess players somehow didn't even really
internalize the possibility that a
computer would be the world chess
champion what I have here is a chart
that I found as I was doing my research
and obviously shouldn't take these
estimated ratings as you know specific
point estimate they're sort of rounded
estimate but it's actually surprising
how accurate it's seen
to be and on the right in the notes I've
I've noted a few very sort of salient
items for each time period that helps us
fix what the relevant strength of the
computer was at the time so as we see
there seems to be a pattern where
roughly every five years the best
computer in the world is gaining about
200 elo points and what I've done to try
to to contextualize that is show well
what's the expected score of the best
computer in the world versus the world
chess champion if we assume the world
chess champion has 2800 rating and of
course as you can see for many many
years the expected score is zero so you
could just sort of like ignore this
thing happening over on the side in 1978
the International master David Levy
quite handily defeated probably the best
computer in the world in 1978 match I
don't know what David Levy's ela rating
was but if we assume it was around 20
350 let's say and let's say he was
probably playing a strong a player as an
opponent then sure that makes sense he
didn't just win every game but he sort
of won handily right five years later
well maybe five six years later
thankfully I'm not gonna pronounce his
name right I apologize but shoo and
Marie Campbell start working together on
the deep thought program and by 1988
deep thought begins competing and chest
ones and I'm actually old enough to
remember when deep thoughts started
competing in chess tournaments so I
remember deep thought being beaten very
handily by Walter brown but on the other
hand deep thought defeated Alex Fishbein
in a game and I actually specifically
remember it was a rook and Bishop versus
rook endgame and you could watch on the
computer screen the computers evaluation
and at the very end when it was a forced
checkmate there was actually a message
that said sorts terminated which I
thought was kind of a funny funny a
funny thing but so we see that yeah
2,400 seems about right this computer
competing and it's not competing at
Grandmaster level but it is able to hold
its own against strong masters and
occasionally even be fairly I know
senior strong senior masters in 1995
let's say roughly 2600 okay well Gary
Kasparov won his first match against
deep blue four to two right obviously
facing a very significant opponent and
then of course as we all know a year
later he lost the second match three and
a half two and a half now I was there
for the second match you've probably all
played you've probably played over the
games I would argue the Garry Kasparov
really over prepared himself into some
degree psyched himself out in that match
he chose he really tried to play chess
openings that were somehow playing
against the computers weaknesses rather
than simply playing the openings that
played to his strengths and so the two
games that he lost there was a reuleaux
pass which he just had a very passive
position and then this disastrous
caro-kann where he allowed a well-known
sacrifice in the opening he just thought
the computer wouldn't sacrifice a piece
for for position but it did it had a
tremendous advantage and he just sort of
lost a very sort of a very poor game I
think if if Gary had been playing up to
his true strength I think he probably
would have won in the match three and a
half two and a half but we can see he's
he's playing an opponent that's roughly
his level five years later one of the
best computers in the world scores three
and a half out of four games against
four very strong torn grandmasters in a
tournament there was another computer
Hydra that beat the Grandmaster Michael
Adams by five and a half half so at this
point already by the middle of last
decade the best computers are sort of
surpassing grandmasters and of course
afterwards computers just keep getting
better and better and now it's not even
worth Magnus Carlsen playing a match
against best computer in the world
because he knows he'd just be he just
lose almost all his games so we're a
very quick primer on how sort of the
method that developed
Cheska
Computers all the way from the 1950s
really until just a few years ago works
so chess players in the audience first
one raise your hand who can spot the
force win all right I saw your hand
first what is it Knight f7 and then
after King well if Roop takes Knight
then what okay
so after King g8 and King h8 and another
seven right chuck me
you
okay now how did you solve this okay
and you knew the pattern okay so so you
look for a check you saw the pattern of
the force checkmate probably also you
notice that the Queen's are opposing
each other so the key thing you had to
notice is Knight f7 check if we're up
takes Knight Queen takes Queen and then
after that you just you just see the
pattern right now that's not how the
computer solves this position right so
the how does the computer solve the
position well the computer lists out all
of the legal moves and then it just
starts searching every single one as far
as it can go by evaluating the sort of
terminus position as as far as it can go
and then it back tracks to choose the
optimal move how does it evaluate the
position well it has these hand coded
handcrafted evaluation rules that are
actually really really complex and
sophisticated at this point because it's
literally been developed over more than
50 years and there are also some
selective search techniques that are
applied right so the in principle the
computer is listing out every single
legal move and then every single legal
response and then every single legal
response and out and out and out and out
and out but because that tree multiplies
exponentially right to get so large so
fast
there are some methods for pruning the
tree and there are some methods for
selectively looking ahead or prior one
extra move or prioritizing some moves
over others but basically fundamentally
what it's doing is its brute force
listing out all the moves going out as
far as it can applying its handcrafted
evaluation function and then working
back like tons and tons and tons of work
have gone in to optimize it but
fundamentally it's the same approach
that's operated for decades now one of
the things that can happen is what's
called a horizon effect so we have
another chess position who can find
yes queen g6 now it took you a little
bit longer why it's actually much
shorter it's only two moves and the last
one took like four or five moves yeah
cuz it's a weird position right it
doesn't look like a smothered made it is
a smothered mate
you
it just doesn't look like one by the way
for those of you who want to sort of
geek out it may look at first that Queen
takes h7 also works because if rook
takes Knight Queen h5 checking if a
queen h8 mate
but actually after Queen takes h7 Bishop
b4 check and then whatever response rook
takes Knight and actually Black has a
winning position in that because of the
material
you
now granted this is a bizarre position
why is there no work on a wand how on
earth would this position arise like
okay we get it
it's a weird position but in some sense
that's the point right to us humans even
though you know you solved this position
after maybe 20 seconds it did take you
probably an extra 10 seconds or so even
though even though it's actually much
shorter search for the computer it would
be much faster I mean obviously at this
point we're talking probably fractions
of seconds but still because it has to
search much less far but another thing I
want to emphasize in this in this
position is the horizon effect and the
horizon effect is well what if animal
yes this is a weird position but but but
hypothetically somehow the computer got
to this position in a search and said
okay well obviously black is winning
this because you know this position is
you know massive material advantage but
if it could just look one move farther
it would see that there's a checkmate
now in point of fact there are there are
particular heuristics that computers use
where probably that wouldn't you know in
in positions like this where pieces are
on pries and so forth it actually has
rules to tell it to look ahead one more
but the general idea is that this
horizon effect had had for many years
bedeviled computers they eventually the
computers got so strong that it was no
longer relevant because the computers
were just better than humans all over
the place so we were never pushing them
up against their horizons but it's still
an intrinsic element to the brute-force
approach right intrinsically on the
you're covering everything but you're
only going out so far and you can reach
that horizon and what I want to show you
later on is actually I think some alpha
zero was in a very severe was actually a
very sort of sophisticated way in which
stockfish ran into a horizon effect in
alpha0 which I'll show in one of the
games but for now I just want to fix
this idea like okay this is horizon of
fact that it's just an intrinsic element
of the brute-force approach all right
now let's start talking about artificial
intelligence so as I was saying a little
while ago artificial intelligence is a
catch-all phrase and it really just sort
of describes any attempt to program
computers to simulate thinking and I put
thinking in scare quotes because we're
not gonna try to define thinking right
but just sort of let's say say doing
something without relying upon explicit
input-output rules there were lots of
different approaches but the current
wave AI wave and by the way I should say
like there have been periods of time
when we have had excitement around AI
it's hard for us to remember this but
there was a lot of excitement around AI
in the 1970s there was a lot of
excitement around ie I in the 1980s
I mean self-driving cause I ton
self-driving cars which I personally
think is actually a little bit has
gotten ahead of itself we've had self
autonomous vehicles of some sort or
another for quite a long time so there
have actually been sort of waves of
excitement around AR but this current AI
wave is really much bigger than before
and I think it's it's it's there's very
legitimate reasons there's tremendous
capabilities that that artificial
intelligence techniques have have been
able to to produce and it's based on a
specific approach called machine
learning using neural networks which I'm
going to unpack in a minute so for the
moment let's take a look at the Box on
the right where I want to contrast
traditional computer programming with
machine learning so let's not worry
about what the machine learning is we're
going to unpack that over the next
couple of slides at the top we have
traditional computer programming right
so for example this is how all computer
chess programs before alpha zero really
operated basically all you have
handcrafted rules and you you feed in
input and the rules and the operate on
the input to produce the output
with machine learning what you do is you
feed an input and you feed in sample
output and then there is a process and
there are many different machine
learning processes but as I'll describe
its neural networks that's really sort
of gotten all of the produce all of the
progress over the last so during this
decade but whatever process you use
there's there's some process of machine
learning which then produces its own
rules those rules then can operate on
fresh input to produce new output but
that's the contrast between traditional
computer programming and machine
learning now let's start to unpack what
I mean by what we mean by a neural
network words sometimes carry meaning or
let's say associations that may not be
accurate to the topic at hand so forget
whatever associations for the moment you
have with network or neural the word
network here just refers to the way the
inputs and the manipulation of the
inputs to sort of interim output and
final output is related specifically you
have arrays of data which are
manipulated using linear algebra that's
basically all we're talking about it's
just the mathematical relationship of
the inputs and the manipulations of the
inputs to the final output which at its
core is linear algebra the word neural
is basically a metaphor it's a reference
to how neurons are thought to function
as a network in the brain but it's we
really have to have we're not gonna talk
about the brain we're not about neurons
anymore in this and I really have to
emphasize we have absolutely no reason
to think that neurons in the brain are
operating using linear algebra right
there is it is absolutely just a
metaphor it's just a description that's
kind of colorful to help us understand
what this network is it doesn't actually
describe in any way the way it functions
and then there were two key tools at
work
which we're going to get to in a few
minutes one as I talked about these
arrays of inputs right map to
intermediate ultimate outputs basically
using linear algebra and then secondly
we'll get to this in a couple slides
back propagation which measures the
fitness of the actual output to the
desired output using gradient descent
and we'll unpack what all those words
mean in a couple minutes so why didn't
the role network base machine learning
become all the rage it's not a new
technology that's actually kind of funny
thing it was really first developed like
back in the old days back when they were
debating what approaches to use to apply
to chess and this key breakthrough of
using gradient descent for back
propagation that developed over 20 years
ago so it's not that the some new
technique was developed really I mean
obviously there have been refinements
but if it's not really like there have
been some there's some big breakthrough
in terms of the the techniques it's
really first of all the hardware got
good enough fast enough
powerful enough that you could build
dense enough networks that it that once
you got to a level of density and I've
read I've been told that for whatever
reasons of six layers so six six sort of
intermediate layers turned out to be
like this this tipping point I have no
idea why and then the second reason is
you had this huge data sets partly
because you were accumulating decades of
knowledge for example people have been
there are huge libraries of cat photos
that people have been using for AI for a
long long time but really because of the
internet and really because of the big
internet giants like Google and Facebook
and they started building applications
that were good enough for people to use
and then once people started using them
that generated more data which made the
applications better and you got this
positive flywheel going so there were so
these are really sort of the two big
things that happened and that's what
what got it what got this sort of
revolution going
and in a couple slides we're going to
come back to and we're going to unpack
there were two sort of key flavors of
machine learning there are two sort of
different types of machine learning
which it's important to understand the
distinction between them to understand
alpha 0 1 is called supervised learning
the others reinforcement 1 we'll get to
that in a minute but first let's talk
about back propagation and gradient
descent so what we've done what we've
covered so far is what basically machine
learning is what basically a neural
network is that we have this way of
organizing the data and the way the data
is manipulated as you sort of the inputs
and the outputs you feed them into the
network and then you get to the end but
when you get to the end there needs to
be this feedback mechanism it needs to
go back and somehow inform that network
to change the way that network is
organized to make it work better
that's what back propagation is so you
start with an input X right it goes to a
certain layer right which is just a data
transformation right and there are
weights so let's say what we want to do
is we want to recognize an image let's
say we want to we want to recognize cat
images and remember everything is
digital here right so when we talk about
a cat image like when you talk about
well when you think about learning to
recognize ok what's a cat and what's not
a cat you think in terms of whiskers you
think in terms of sort of the proportion
of the body maybe sort of the way the
face looks some of those can kind of be
quantified some of these not but they're
really more conceptual for a computer
it's where pixels are right it's very
specifically placements of pixels and so
there have to be equations there have to
be relationships weights that tell the
computer is sort of when pixels are
arranged in this way it's a cat when
it's not a
when this arranged this way it's not a
cap so you're feeding in images of cats
which is to say basically just whole
bunches of pixels and different
arrangements it's transforming it in
certain ways at first randomly by the
way because you got to start somewhere
and then it it puts out a prediction cat
not cat cat not cat right and you know
which ones are cats and which ones are
not cats
so every time something comes out the
other end the computer says cat knocking
cat not cat you are map matching it up
to whether it actually is a cat we're
not a cat you put those together that
gives you you you and somehow you
compare the two in a loss function a
loss function basically says how much
information was lost like you know which
which images of cats are not cats that's
the information you have and you're
feeding this through the network through
through this neural network and the
computer is making certain predictions
and it's not right in fact at first its
random so there's lots of information
being lost and you have to apply some
function that allows you to quantify the
amount of information that's lost that
generates a score and that score then
has to be fed back that's back
propagation and there's an optimizer
that oval there is what I'm going to
describe on the right there's an
optimizer which gives you some way of
adjusting the weights that is a that
will be applied to the transformation of
data as you feed more images in so that
you lose less information and that's
that's what's going on you just you're
just gonna sort of spin that wheel over
and over and over again that optimizer
is called gradient descent so for those
of you who know calculus basically what
we're trying to do is find a local
minimum that's what calculus is but we
don't know what the equation is right
and by the way on the right I've showed
just a simple curve but in reality we're
dealing with lots of variables but we
just want a simple curve so we can
picture it
so we don't know what the equation is
but we're trying to find a local minimum
so we're using this approach which is
called gradient descent
it's called gradient descent because
you're sort of going out some and
descending some and going out some and
descending some and then at some point
you get to a local minima now obviously
what we're picturing here is very smooth
right in reality who knows what the
shape of that is you don't know ex-ante
or I'll priori what the shape of that is
so it's much much more complicated than
a simple picture I'm pacing here but the
concept is you're you're going out and
you're following mathematical procedures
to find a place where you think you've
reached a local minimum have you reached
the absolute minimum no but you don't
need to you don't need to absolutely
minimize the loss of information you
just need to adjust the weights in some
way that you make enough progress that
you can just keep going because the next
time you feed more information in it's
gonna lose less information and it's
gonna lose it in different ways and you
can just keep optimizing and keep
optimizing and keep optimizing and then
at the end you've built a set of rules
and that's in a nutshell what artificial
what this type of artificial
intelligence using their neural networks
is this this is the the back propagation
process that allows you to take your
outputs use it to inform what it's doing
so that it works better okay so now
we're going to contrast these two
flavors of our of neural networks
machine learning a machine learning
using neural networks supervised
learning and reinforcement learning
basically on the Left this is a picture
of what we call supervised learning and
you can really think of supervised
learning as sort of mapping X to Y and
the basic idea here is you you know what
the right answer is so if it's auto
correct for your thumb the right answer
is if you accept the word then the wrong
answer is if you go back and delete it
right if it's
an ad targeting program the right answer
is if you click on it and the wrong
answer is if you don't click on it and
on and on and on right whatever it is
you're mapping X to Y some input to
output and this is basically the process
that I described but we can also have
what's called reinforcement learning
which we apply when we don't actually
have the right answer we can just say
you're getting closer or you're getting
farther away so an example of this is
self-driving cars right so like you you
can't really say like success I mean
obviously you don't want to hit somebody
right but but it's it's it's really
tricky to define exactly like what what
is right or wrong it's much more closer
farther away you did a better job you
did a less good job so what we need to
do here it's more it's more complex you
need to monitor the response of the
actions taking me to score the response
in some fashion so that you're either
getting closer to or farther away from
the ultimate goal and it turns out it
just turns out that where the
reinforcement learning process has
really been successful so far is with
games supervised ly like 95 percent I
mean that's not a precise number but the
vast vast vast majority of what
companies are using artificial
intelligence for today is supervised
learning it's where you have a
well-defined right answer wrong answer
the reinforcement learning is an area of
tremendous excitement because it could
input in theory be much more
generalizable it's also harder in many
ways but one of the reasons why chess
once again turns out to be such an
important such a useful problem for
computer science is that chess turns out
and go beforehand turns out to have been
a really good problem to apply
reinforcement learning tune so what we
can now say and obviously I'm grossly
oversimplifying something very
complicated but how does alpha zero work
alpha zero is a reinforcement learning
deep neural network that uses repeated
self play to train itself so the neural
network right we have to what what is
the output we know what the input is the
inputs pretty straightforward it's the
board position what's the output so what
they just what they developed was a way
to have two outputs at the same time
what they called a policy vector and a
value score so the policy vector is an
array of expected probabilities what
what move the computer expects to be
played at each step of the search and
then the value network is the expected
outcome of the game at the end now this
there has to be a search algorithm right
because you can't search the whole game
you need to have some way to truncate
the tree because you can't feed in games
and and tell the computer oh just just
take this one position and play out
every single possible possibility all
the way to the end there has to be a way
to truncate that and it's called Monte
Carlo tree search which we'll get to in
a minute and and I'll explain the
intuition behind it I certainly won't be
able to explain the math behind it but
I'll explain the intuition behind it and
basically the reinforcement learning
process works as follows write the
probability weights initially sent
randomly all it knows at the beginning
is the rules of the game and then large
batches of games are played running this
Monte Carlo tree search algorithm from
the current position each turn right and
so what it does it just sort of like
randomly goes out and and some searches
it says okay I can't search every game I
can't I can't take a position and search
it all the way out to the end but I'm
gonna search a lot of it out bet them on
you call it research algorithm and then
I'm going to come back and at first it
doesn't randomly and at the end of every
game there's a plus one minus one right
everything's got to be math right so win
draw loss and then it updates its neural
network weights so as to maximize the
similarity of its policy vector to the
search probabilities and minimize the
error between the predicted outcome in
the game outcome and what we see here is
it's really quite extraordinary that as
it went out it starts it doesn't know
anything right it has an Euler rating of
zero if that's possible it very quickly
gets up to a pretty good level and then
as it keeps playing thousands and
thousands millions really right because
each mini batch is 4096 training
positions and and the x-axis is
thousands of those right so as it keeps
going out it just gets better and better
and better and in fact even surpasses
stockfish so let's let's sort of unpack
Monte Carlo tree search so the
underlying intuition here is you want a
process that will allow you to take us
any position and just sort of search all
the way out to the end so remember the
way that stockfish works or any sort of
brute-force approach it takes a set of
rules and then it searches sort of
everything out each next iteration not I
mean as we said not actually right there
are some rules for sort of pruning the
tree and so forth but basically
conceptually it's just sort of like it's
going out and out and out sort of like
this ever-expanding fan and at some
point it hits our horizon what this AI
approach does what alpha zero does is it
sort of goes really deep all the way to
the end of course you know it's
branching out now now now now but it has
ways
cutting that tree really viciously and
then sort of coming all the way back and
updating what it thinks it knows the
various weights based on the results of
that so you might say well at first like
well that's crazy like how could you how
could you possibly make progress doing
that but amazingly it turns out I mean
it takes a lot takes millions and
millions but it doesn't take you know
trillions and quadrillions it takes
enough that makes it tractable so you
can sort of like go out and then come
back and then you go out again and
you're Monte Carlo tree search has been
updated by the weight from with the
weights that you learn the first time
and you come back and keep doing that
over and over again and now it turns out
that you search is much more intelligent
that's basically what's going on here
and the diagram on the right comes from
the paper I hope you can I know it's
small I apologize I hope you can see
that diagram what they are showing here
and by the way it's a beautiful game if
you if you haven't played through it I
highly recommend it's a lovely game so
alpha zero is white and in this position
against black stockfish it is it first
in the first hundred simulations it is
considering up to ten different
candidate moves then sort of each it
goes ten to third to the fourth to the
fifth so it's you know each each you
know ten times more simulations when it
does ten times more simulations the
first time it's really only looking at
c6 and d4 and then ten times more after
that it's it's still looking at 66 and
d5 but now it's weighting d5 more
heavily than c6 the the the number
corresponds to its value score like what
it thinks is the probability of winning
from the position so basically at first
it thought it had if I can read that
number correctly it thought it had a 60%
probability of winning this position but
then pretty quickly it got to a level
that it roughly it's data
70% probability and I thought c6 was the
best move versus d5 but then actually as
it went farther it decided d5 was the
right move versus c6 and eventually sort
of as it goes out to the end of it as
far as you can go
it it settles on d5 as being the right
move and so this is illustrating how the
Monte Carlo process is working obviously
this is when it's function is fully
developed as opposed to when it's
training itself sort of applying sort of
at first a random then very rudimentary
and then sort of continually updating
itself to get better and better now just
a funny thing about alpha zero
paradoxically even though alpha zero
produces just that seems more human-like
it's actually much less transparent it's
it's a it's a bizarre thing right like
if you've played over the games of alpha
zero versus the games of stockfish there
is something I mean of course like stock
fish is amazing right stocks will crush
any human in the world easily but
there's something machine-like about the
stock fish games or any sort of
traditional chess program whereas the
games of alpha zero it seems like sort
of I don't know like you know what would
happen if God came down and touched Nick
how tall or something right it's like
it's like somehow like like the
superhuman version of the great chess
players it looks somehow more human-like
and yeah for stock fish we actually know
exactly what it's doing because we built
all the rules I mean not me or you but
but human beings built all the rules so
it's completely transparent what stock
fish was actually doing work but for
alpha zero what was built was the
process for it to generate its own rules
we don't actually know what its rules
are
we kind of have to infer what its rules
are somehow and but we never really will
because remember think back to the sort
of image recognition for cat photos for
example you know we now have image
recognition programs that are very good
there is basically as good at
recognizing cat photos as humans are but
in the end it's basically equations that
relate pixels to one another it's not
whiskers and sort of you know like it's
got this kind of shape of face and it's
not conceptual the way it is with with
humans it's not something you can
somehow explaining and the same thing is
true for alpha zero and the chest that
it's producing so it's an interesting
it's an interesting paradox and
something worth worth thinking about I
think there's also I think it's really
worth thinking about the horizon effect
as it manifests with stockfish and alpha
zero now I assume you all are familiar
with this game right this is one of the
most famous games where alpha zero beat
stockfish so this is Queen's Indian you
know if position on the Left white could
have just played Knight g4 but instead
white played rook e1 and alpha zero
thought after rook e1 it had a small
advantage but not a big advantage so it
had a probability score somewhere sort
of I think in the upper 50s maybe
whereas alpha zero is like well I'm
winning tonight and yes of course it has
rules for like it knows it's Kings is
exposed and it's behind in development
and so on and so forth but according to
its rules it just has a big advantage in
the position and it's looking out as far
as I can and it can't see sort of how
it's going to lose now much further on
in the game apologize for this being cut
off down below but much further often in
the game we reach this position on the
left and white played like this really
incredible move see
for it's just god it's beautiful I mean
it's just like it's just such a
beautiful move it turns out like there's
no obvious way for white to intensify
the attack and see for it just like
turns out to be like this really
powerful move because it's it's
threatening it to open up the see file
which opens up this new line of attack
it cuts off the Queen it just sort of
like it just sort of like it uses that
little last ounce of a force in the
position to pry it open now there's no
earthly way that stockfish could have
seen this position when it was
considering capturing the knight like
it's just it's so far beyond its horizon
it's laughable but it's perfectly
possible
remember the Monte Carlo tree search
process right like like alpha zero goes
really deep it's pruning like crazy it's
going really deep it may very well have
seen this position so in some sort of
very strange sense we're seeing the
horizon effect manifests itself again
but at the same time the Monte Carlo
tree search process has its own weakness
right and we there are I didn't I didn't
put it here because it was just too
difficult to try to show but there's
apparently in the in the earlier
iteration that played the go match
against Lisa at all I don't know go well
enough to be able to verify this I've
just read that apparently it it in the
one game that it lost it made a very
peculiar kind of error and the error
that it made seems to have been due to
an earlier iteration of the way it's
Monte Carlo tree search process worked
there was also a game that it lost
against stockfish and in that game
obviously you know it won most of the
games can stock fish but but there was
one endgame where it had a it was one
they sort of like good night versus bad
Bishop end games and basically like
there's no way
you could lose this position if all you
just wanted to do was sort of putter
around and what it did was it sort of
went for this attempt to win but it
seems to have just missed this kind of
long narrow single path where in fact
this way of attempting to win lost right
it actually like jettisoned upon and
like you know what tried too hard to win
it's kind of like almost of the human
like trying too hard the win but in this
case it's a particular feature of its
Monte Carlo tree search process so it's
it's possible that we will see
weaknesses or shortcomings of the of the
artificial intelligence approach that
alpha0 uses going back to the cat
imaging this is a well-known phenomenon
in other kinds of AI applications where
you can take an image that to human eyes
literally cannot be distinguished
between another image so you have sort
of Cat Cat and it's just like literally
looks like they're exactly the same
photo but in fact what you've done is
you've just changed a few pixels and it
turns out that like it thinks one is a
cat and like one is a horse or something
it's like you get like very strange
outcomes like that because there's
something about the weighting of these
of the of this function that leads
itself open to these sort of like narrow
weaknesses these sort of like chinks in
the armor you could almost think about
it that's very difficult to understand
right because remember it is this kind
of block box like diagnosing this and
trying to anticipate it seems to be very
difficult so anyway that's the end of my
comments and I'd be happy to take any
questions or just talk about I think
artificial intelligence itself is super
exciting and I think it's the most
exciting thing that happened in chess in
a long long time I think we're just at
the beginning of of seeing how it's
going to affect chess
[Music]